wherever you're watching this from  around the world i want to welcome you  to the global teacher prize ceremony  2020.  this year in particular we all owe our  teachers a huge debt of gratitude  i know from personal experience how  great teachers  can dramatically change the course of a  young person's life for the better  that's why teaching really is a  profession like no other  because as a teacher you're only  responsible for educating our young  people  but encouraging them too and nothing  could be more  important now i'd like to introduce  you to a very special host this evening  he's a british  national treasure speaking to you for  one of our capitals  most treasured buildings i am so  delighted  to welcome stephen fry who's standing at  the entrance  of the natural history museum in london